welcome to a new episode of not too deep
the award-winning podcast I'm your host
grace and how big the first we have an
amazing guest an incredibly exciting
episode it's Topher Grace you may know
him from that 70s show you might know
him from various other things that you
can IMDB him about that I didn't really
ask him about it also it doesn't really
matter what he does have that I know
about is an incredible new podcast
called miner adventures and we talked a
lot about just his high school
experience the transition of getting on
that 70 show and how he slid into the
Facebook private messages to find his
wife if he can do it you can do it too
this is a really fun episode enjoy it
with Topher Grace oh not too deep this
is episode of not too deep is brought to
you by you probably guessed it already
Squarespace turn your great ideas into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project if you're gonna showcase work or
sell products of any kind they got
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
make a very beautiful and unique website
all by yourself but if you do get stuck
they have 24/7 award-winning customer
support that is there to help you out
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain
[Music]
topher thank you for being here grace
thank you for having me yeah this is I
try to start like Larry King and then it
just be this official yeah it devolves
immediately my wife said when I left the
house if you and I got married you would
be great grace grace grace grace squared
yeah what's your middle name and grace
and grace that sounds like I have
Tourette's
so she's threatened it's basically what
it sounds like yeah she said you tell
that [ __ ] um welcome one two not too
deep but also welcome to the podcast
world you just launched your podcast
yeah I'm not gonna be as good as you
really just starting this is what we
call it [ __ ] here so your will be
fine no you're actually a real host I
was they found a format for me where I
don't have to host it I'm kind of like
someone's buddy going on this adventure
with them okay explain to me because I
started to listen to the Whitney
Cummings episode which is the first
episode that aired and the last we're
doing so much research but you said you
listened to at least five minutes of it
I you know I saw her posted on her
Instagram story know the premise of that
episode gave me anxiety
by osmosis because you strapped her to a
lie-detector test without her permission
pre beforehand well I do all this stuff
too so it's not like we're just doing it
to the guest so what's the premise of
this podcast the premises when it says
minor adventures right what it means is
little in-studio
adventures you go on so that's one is
that we took a lie-detector test but the
next week Paul Scheer and I we did kind
of telemarketing kind of competitive
telemarketing we'd a got a robo machine
caller and we called all of LA and so I
mean this will come out after that
podcast whoo right so we've had we did
like beatboxing with Krissy Metz and we
did dream analysis with taran killam
are these all like bucket list things
for you or these are just random no I
went on on a pharisee podcast uh-huh
this is so much fun it really is
something about not being on camera I
think I am tagged
no no no so you can you can reduce this
shirt offense yeah you can give middle
fingers to me this entire time and still
seem charming I think it would affect
the chemistry well I I went on that show
and she was she's an old friend of mine
and she was so cool and it was so much
fun and then her producer said do you
want to kind of called me a couple weeks
later let's go out to lunch mm-hmm I
said I want you to do your podcast his
wife want to do a podcast I'd be a
terrible host
he said no I have this idea for a format
uh-huh where you don't have like already
what you've done I'm terrible at that
kind of place welcome and you know hello
hi well that's the thing that podcasts
and they afford you the opportunity to
not have any formality at all or any
sort of like for lack of a better word
grace and I like eloquence in anything
whatever you have to do which is zero I
don't even less cool which is like I
just talked to my friends and then they
bring in an expert like Pete Holmes just
came in I brought in the guy who wrote
Dothraki for Game of Thrones what and we
created a language like every single we
have one coming up that I can't even
tell about cuz the person might hear
what it is it is so you the most insane
thing so it's a blind they're going in
blind
basically your guests to every single
episode something you're deciding
whether or not you're gonna come on
ready no to me I'm talking I'm talking
myself through the actual like if I ever
got asked what I do this and probably
and no because I'm what constantly
paranoid I'm gonna be kidnapped in my
life anyway so I'm not gonna do I don't
know what you guys escape now this is
our version of an escape room I've never
like this is what do you know what I've
been picturing my whole life go
somewhere great some people comment like
we did like kind of Reiki and I was you
know like I don't even know what that
was but yeah you know some people love
what we're doing and some people are
nervous but all of it the best was Louis
house you know Lewis house no he he's
like a motivational speaker he's like a
great guy I want like lots of different
types of people on and he came in and we
had in the biggest pop song writer she
writes for like Beyonce uh-huh and we
wrote a pop song and then at the end I
don't know if I should say this because
it hasn't aired yet Matt Nathanson
covered it because the her manager was
he's like Allah send this to match that
and now it's like a pop song so it's
like you could win a Grammy it's what
you're saying I know I she did such a
good job of writing it and we were such
like by standards it made me feel like
Taylor Swift and all these people are
like cheating by saying they're
co-writing these songs woman was amazing
but I signed over off I truly didn't she
really wrote the song and we were like
we had like one thing that rhymes or
something that's great has anything gone
bad
Oh mostly for me yeah tickets came in oh
we did auctioneering like livestock on
your life and one yeah that's terrifying
actually do it takes but years of
practice and I was like why it's just
talking fast but if you really try to
count and know I couldn't even do it on
that whole hour that whole episodes
because what's been have there been any
I guess like creative skills that you've
pocketed now that are like of interest
to you right so it doesn't involve you
as a human in any way but it's a good
time it's like you learn something but
the more foreign it is the better okay
so yeah we're doing the same thing for a
while and it feels like going to well
that's I was gonna ask you that because
I do a lot of YouTube stuff forever and
so to do a podcast in the beginning was
like a real it was weird but it was like
a very fun different thing to creatively
do because now something you have to do
now has become the thing that makes me
and my dog money and allows us to live
and eat so I still love it very
organically and created and I do it for
me not for the paycheck the heat but
it's a weird different muscle to flex
yeah for me especially because of the
you know sometimes I know very little
about what the event she's gonna
beatboxing oh my god or breath came in
and we did spinning like learning from a
DJ and I was so bad like throw so bad
that I but it kind of it's entertaining
either way really especially maybe
better if you're bad so busily the
premise is like this it's why Topher
became an actor these are all the job
outlets that you could not succeed in so
we got
you and as an audience think I'm more
capable than I met I am I'm gonna prove
you one job for me I'm okay but that
sounds really fun there I mean so you
guys get to keep doing it until someone
says stop I don't know what the bar is I
mean you could tell me I mean it's kind
of like no idea I I love it and you know
we had a kid a year and a half ago and
like once a week I get to leave my house
now mm-hmm and do something like that's
the time you want to do it yeah actually
the time you want to go to a liberal
arts school yeah it's like when you have
a kid and you like go out of your house
have a child and that will really
amplify it oh yeah yeah my agents like
is there anything on location zealanders
the thing I admire the most about the
podcast is the marketing campaign you
have created a series of billboards and
bus ads that a picture right it's us
Fabio a little picture how did I just
had to get in the gym for a couple
months that photo shoot was bananas and
I just kind of my wife said now do you
not take a slim down all you want to be
relatable again it's funny because I
showed my wife and she's like I don't
think that's funny because I think she
has to find me attractive but then
everyone else we showed the picture to
like cracks up when I saw I got mad
addicts I wish I had thought of that as
a marketing tool for anything I've done
creatively because it is so Fabio is a
literal Unicorn of a human we were
thinking like adventures and like we
were thinking different like am I going
through the jungle with a machete you
want people to know the same thing we
had to record a theme song it's weird I
never realized until doing a podcast you
only have one opportunity to show
visually what it is and one opportunity
to kind of musically show what it is
yeah and so we spent a lot of time is
really you know another fun kind of
hobby thing to do is going how do we do
like a cool theme
and still says this isn't you know
exactly mission impossible sure and the
same thing with the poster how do we say
adventure but it's like kind of funny
what's been have you had any of your
friends family or just miscellaneous
people see the these billboards see
these wrapped fans and buses and
situations and not understand is that
real is this a movie you're doing what
is this like what is this can I swear on
this that yeah you can swear it as much
as possibly you is like an Arnold
Schwarzenegger tired did you have to get
Fabio's like permission for something
like that no I'll tell you what we did
do though this was awesome huh was we I
kind of had the idea with a group of
people who work on I mean the people who
are doing the podcasts are like I mean
this is samsara is on apheresis producer
oh cool he's on my show too and he's
unbelievable so we kind of had this idea
and then he's like I will find artists
we'll do something like a Harlequin
romance novel yeah cover and then we
went wait why don't we find the guy who
does it maybe it's no one's gonna be as
good as these covers we're looking at
and this guy lives in New Jersey that's
my home state yeah we called him up it's
like yeah habits you tomorrow it was
like it was so fast it was the guy so I
don't think you follow you because
Fabio's from like the 90s really in
terms of those covers but he had I mean
I I'm gonna go like really behind the
scenes here please do not actually my
body it's actually like another model is
you can believe it with these goddamn
ruined I know so this is a little
special food viewers my hair the but he
hit a library of like tons of bodies I
just got to go through and say like that
one you have to choose which body was
your criterion for that um just
realistic somebody's really looks like
yeah have you met this man in person
that designed this I know we spoke over
the phone
I hope okay he did a great job yeah I
mean it looks great it was yeah it's
only the only thing that's off is it
it's me
like I mean truly like that's the best
spoof is when it's only 1% off like so
it's really kind of a great picture we
might do a different one for season two
or so you guys have to come out with now
a fake romance novel it's like ancillary
kind of content for this thing I would
love that
no it's fantastic and yeah it seems
really fun and a great concept to just
like try a bunch of [ __ ] with a bunch of
people that don't know that they're
about the try bunch I've been hearing
nice things but truly before we it came
out which at this point was like two
weeks ago I knew I was having a blast
that's the only way when I'm doing a
movie too that I know people tell you
movies gonna be successful or not or
whatever but you know you're having a
great time doing it usually that's a you
check in with yourself and just sort of
monitor it like for real for real yeah
okay so you just had well one I'm
curious about because I go into
everyone's social media before they come
as I guess on the podcast just see if
they use it if they don't use it I'm
always curious when like more quote
traditional actors actresses
participated social media what does that
mean because I'm from the YouTube space
like there's you know and I feel like
podcast toe the line there like the
thing like the bridge that kind of ties
everything that we're meeting right here
we're meeting here exactly like this the
fact that anyone would call me
traditional is like bananas by
traditional human boring nice you get
you had some gatekeepers the guy you
should that said you are allowed to do
with the thing that you really enjoyed
doing genuinely well that's true that is
a good but you do social media you do
participate like do you have a favorite
platform Instagram yeah that's I was
gonna guess that that would be the one
that it's you hashtag you know really
I'm not good at any of that but you
actually been like a bat-like a purpose
it seems like a purposely bad way well
it's like dad Instagram skills but
here's what I know is about four years
ago someone took me aside and was like
this is your right one of those handlers
was like you're not a stagnant by doing
nothing
you're actually going backwards like
it's not just that you're you're
actually not so I made a deal with
myself to like I think it's true you
know I think because some people have
such a hold of it even traditional
action or sure yeah so I couldn't do any
of that you know when you're holding the
phone you're like hey guys I just
arrived at Burger King and now I'm going
but like I do I made a promise myself to
put this sounds so laborious but I made
a promise to post twice a week that's
great and like you know it's tough
you're with your kid and you're like
taking a cell and it feels wrong but
it's gonna ask like what are your now
that your new dad and you're also
participate in the social media world
what do you have I guess like
limitations uh well no pictures of
family yeah the only type of vision of
me my wife is when we're like on a red
carpet yeah and I don't know where to do
that and that just keep it personal but
I also think I'm I mean I said this to
Sam when he's trying to catch me into a
podcast I was like I am legitimately
boring like if someone had a that's what
you're saying traditional is cuz I can't
do the other thing like that now you can
do the thing that I am not good at so
don't where everyone has their own skill
set okay yeah no I mean yeah maybe but
like I'm really my wife and I joke like
if we had a reality show it would be us
watching reality show like there's no
reality show fan my wife isn't she's
turned me into one okay what wouldn't
you guys want that to see we're so we're
so boring sure but now I'm distracted
because I'm a reality show all right
well my wife is dirty when it comes to
reality all of them I mean I guess she's
really into the new it he's like we just
got married but we didn't know each
other she married at first sight we just
watch the reunion special last night
with my boyfriend so what's the reason
special last night too
okay what's going on with that dude man
he makes me mad
I haven't crossed the line to deep dive
into his Grammy I did we did you did yes
okay tell me what's up I mean what can
you say on this every bad but he's
already put his life out there he's put
his life out there dudes gay right I
mean come on he's extremely gay but if
he's not he's homophobic
yeah you're right you're right it's he
makes a joke on Facebook I haven't
checked out the facts of everything she
said okay wait back it up okay what
said was and for anyone who's listening
I'm trying to get good at this basically
there's a panel of experts that people
signed up for this opportunity to
potentially be chosen to be paired with
someone that these experts deem like
their person these experts are terrible
one name is dr. pepper
what is peppers dr. Janet peppers they
knew that they cuz they called her dr.
peppers like the first two seasons and
then they added her other name because I
assume they realize the social media is
like having a [ __ ] field day with it
but the yeah and then they have a it's a
social experiment where they have six
weeks to do you meet at the altar mm-hmm
and this guy from the get-go was like
I'm not attracted to her which is let's
be real like you everyone gets divorced
at the end of the show except for like
two or three couples like you don't have
to say it's like going on a date with
someone and they arrive saying like I'm
not attracted to you physically not my
type he also he ran a speed-dating event
at my time because she does have a dick
no problem with any of it it's just like
why are you you made her feel like [ __ ]
really heat up just to cut to the end
you have sex with her and then go sit by
himself in the living room alone and
tell her you I feel dead inside which is
the most insane thing to say like
honestly two or three tops girls say
that to me I've never said that to my
therapist yet have any problem with him
being gay except that he's married to
this woman and not telling her that he
is gay yeah and he agreed to this social
experiment that's on camera and so hey
it's one of those things that he's
voluntarily participating in what
screaming he's balding he's got he's
trimming back his hair yeah throw these
baby hairs on his forehead that when I
didn't notice that for the first few
episodes of them when I did I couldn't
unsee it like at all I'm looking at when
he's talking he's beyond me this does it
isn't as mean as he is he actually is on
the show yeah and he's crazy - he says
different things those are clearly
placating for cameras oh you can tell
that they probably have a complete they
clearly have a different language that
they talk to each other
yeah yeah that's probably the more
correct word for it but then he
participates like they have some
agreement in which they are like cool
quote unquote on camera with each other
and it's just so transparent and I love
that's the only part of the reunion I
love very much is that the host like
kind of went in on him he was great he
was to be on Entertainment Tonight or
something that guy won the whole show to
me last night
I hated him up until that interview
because I thought he was being too like
quote he goes he goes dude I'm on TV for
a living I'm telling you you look like
[ __ ] right now
some give you an opportunity like oh go
in on him please host wanted to divorce
him yeah just during the interview like
the guys almost divorce upon human we
did a deep dive on social media it's got
pictures of him and I'm fleet week like
running around and he's like I don't
know why he would agree to it that's the
most confusing thing I feel like I'm
just my theory there's nothing right
please parents think he's straight and
he's trying to prove and like an outer
wave at you straight be gay or bi or
anything and going to show and lock
yourself down to a woman who you don't
even like right and then hope that this
woman is really the source for
encryptions the grace she's so sweet and
I felt like she does not attract you
you're not attractive I mean even though
her honeymoon was like oh no can you let
her quit the experiment right now like
let you guys do you guys with plan B for
her just meet someone else because she
deserves love I don't think he does
necessarily right now but she does for
sure also I do I have a theory too that
he had like his speed dating business he
thought would get like exposure on a
reality show like this and might help
him out like in his career who knows
Luke sucks a dick anyway on that note
we're gonna take a quick break some more
questions here oh not you Depot beer
back
[Music]
too deep yes who's fun during today's
episode of not too deep if you get
Squarespace your genius
if you didn't guess it you're still
appreciated for being here and listening
to this ad read but you're not as smart
as the others but that doesn't mean you
still can't turn your great ideas into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself and if you do
get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help head the squarespace.com slash
Grace for a free trial and when you are
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain this episode not Judy
purrs brought to you by Lisa they
believe that a bed is more than just a
place to sleep it's a place for
relaxation and rest and they believe
that every body has the right to rest
that's why they make to awsome
mattresses plus accessories and bases to
give your body the deep rest it needs
the all foam lisa mattress is new and
improved featuring get this cooling LS a
200 foam for enhanced pressure relief
for side sleepers that i don't know what
it is but it sounds like it's gonna help
you if you're a side sleeper and their
superior hybrid mattress is the perfect
combination of foam and spring for
pressure relief and edge to edge support
and their mission is to provide a better
night's sleep for everybody and from day
one they've set out to create a company
with heart that's why they donate one
mattress for every 10 they sell to
organizations that work in causes like
foster care prevention and to date
they've donated more than 32 thousand
mattresses through more than 1,000
nonprofits so not all not only are you
getting yourself a better sleeping
situation you are but indirectly
donating to a wonderful cause like I
said 32,000 mattresses threw over more
than a thousand nonprofits have already
been donated and you can be part of that
and get 15% off your entire order at
Lisa Homme / grace if you use the promo
code grace that's Lisa
L
si.com slash grace promo code grace okay
we're back
would you ever go on a reality show
would you and your wife ever do like
Amazing Race
no no invest no big-time now my wife I
think before we met made a tape for The
Amazing Race so we're in different
places about really I think she's made a
half a one and decide not to do it okay
but I once again just too boring
would you ever what show would you
champion your wife being on what's that
show on it's on Fox it's my husband's
penis is too large it's like I yeah I
feel like that one maybe I watch not
from afar I yeah I'm a big Real
Housewives franchise we're not in that
zone that's like well that's when you
hit rock bottom so you guys are still
safe hanging out that Marcus lemonis
show too which is different a reality
show before he goes and helps small
businesses oh that sounds nice and
rewarding yeah it's called the Prophet
and we like are having like we look
we're two actors like to sit there and
have discussions about businesses case
it went down the shark tank rabbit hole
and it leads to the profit that it's
built profit like you know profit sure
and that shows great - it's inspiring
are you guys gonna you couldn't start a
small business we're gonna franchise our
acting other Topher Grace's okay I have
a so you okay
we're recognized in a murder trial Wow
yes that's true
yeah not to pivot 200 you know this is
the most insane thing to me can we okay
we talk about this is this like public
knowledge
yeah I know i I've talked about it
basically I've been ended for jury duty
a couple times not even gotten picked
okay I've never been into jury duty why
because I still keep my address in New
Jersey so yes like I just also am lazy
you haven't changed man at this point I
think I worked at a bunch of movies in a
row so as enjoying having downtime
I thought I was thinking about I was
reading a script about being a lawyer
and I was like you know I think I want
to get on a trial and I got picked and
you're in this room where you know
they're kind of whittling down to have
people into a 12-person jury and I
thought they said there's a murder trial
I thought it's me great I could
experience that I should have and see
how lawyers really talk and then they
bring in the guy and it's they say you
know this is you know innocent until
proven guilty that's our system this guy
walks in he's guilty
you can tell yeah it's everything short
of having an eyepatch he was like
totally did it even what the crime was
this guy's guilty of it like this guy's
murdered maybe not someone in this trial
but someone for sure and he kind of sits
there and they say everyone they made us
rise and take an oath or something and
they said do you promise to you know you
know you're all gonna be honest or
whatever and as we sat down I always
wanted part of the promise was do you
know this person in the courtroom
happened to know it but I'm sure there's
times where that happens okay and then
as I sat down he kind of looked over and
kind of just pointed at me and kind of
lipped like big fan oh my god oh my god
and then I didn't know how to get out of
it because I I mean that's I can imagine
this guy coming back in the courtroom
and I'm like like when the person saying
you're you know we all find him guilty
me kind of being like it wasn't me kind
of like a bunch of them you know teamed
up on you and I had to go with sorry
that's insane yeah so I just went up to
the judge and this is the most
embarrassing part at that point you have
to be like I can't be part of this to
say to someone which I don't think I'm
not one of those like I went to clubs or
something like no Do You Know Who I am
technically oh did this judge I was like
hey um I'm slightly in the public eye
and and he was like from what I was like
that 70 show maybe and he's like no I'm
not familiar and I was like come on man
like Ashton could have you heard a
statue I was trying to like then finally
we hit on something that he seems
yeah I've seen you like I didn't like
that project but you don't have says
that's no I've you did it the right way
I've tried to get into a bar in Boston
or Chicago rather with my brothers
because my wallet had gotten stolen the
night before and I had organized like
this brother trip with everyone for the
first time and the security guard at the
front was like no and as the bars
totally update and it's this dive bar
it's a piece of [ __ ] place we just
wanted to go do like karaoke and drink
beer and then my brother's like just
telling like you know the dudes internet
stuff and I was like and then I was like
I can show you like my Wikipedia page
you like no you're good call sir do the
same name as you I'm the piece of [ __ ]
now for you and try ever had this for
someone I mean this is more when people
had like those click cameras and I like
before where they kind of come up you're
in like Vegas or something like would
you mind I'm like sure and I start
posing with them and I know would you
mind taking the pitch oh oh sorry it's
the worst you feel awful at the worst
one ever is I had a guy at a gas station
there's like two or three years into 70s
show go hey hey man no offense you know
I like the kid from that's heavy shot
and I was like wait what none taken sir
yeah anything that starts with no
offense let alone him trying to comfort
you on not being no I've yeah I've had
situations that make me feel like the
worst you whenever is when someone comes
up at like your YouTube videos and you
know you're talking and then you don't
really know how to end the conversation
and so you're just kind of like do you
want to take a picture or anything and
I'm good I've had people say no say no
and I'm like you're right you're you're
right I'm glad that we got to sometimes
people wanna know they don't know know
that's the reason that I started asking
you then I stopped at experience
and so it's really fun I'll see you at
the boarding school oh yeah this is a
deep dive yeah no I just looked at
Wikipedia for 30 yeah I did from a young
age from like 13 Wow did you miss
roommate at boarding school
I had several roommates yeah man yeah
what um I don't know anything about
boarding school boarding school the
thing I have to tell you is if you don't
anything about it everyone thinks it's
like Dead Poets Society or school time
they romanticize this thing this was no
that would be the bad version this is
like boys and girls and you know I was
such a loser in high school I was really
talking to girls earlier than I would
have and it's if you want to go away
that was a huge fan of my hometown so if
you want to go away then it's a great
experience you just come home a big
chunk of the year and spend with your
family and then when you're there it's
like you know you're living next to your
best friends it was like a mini college
I mean it's like a it's a different type
of camp I would imagine yeah it's can't
yeah the best is when there's no work
like when you have a snow day at
boarding school there's nothing better
it's like all your best friends are
hanging out dream movies like so I would
say yeah I only really look back on it
fondly but I was the one who chose to go
I the kids who are always getting kicked
out for doing whippets or like whatever
those kids are they were forced to go do
would you want your daughter to go to
boarding school no if unless she really
wanted to go she would you want her to
enter the entertainment industry no
period really yeah
oh that's interesting I'm always curious
about that because I imagine that it's
one way or the other but I could look if
she was crazy passionate about it and
you know she could do it when she's 18 I
guess yeah but it's more it's not the
the entertainment stuff this what we're
doing right now is the fun stuff is yeah
it's all this other stuff it's just it's
really when I think about the people who
I started with when I was 19 I'm not
talking about the people instead of show
like all the whole like incoming classes
yeah
1998 like some of those people are dead
you know some of them are like sound
like water beds and you know it's like
some are still here trying and it's sad
like you know someone
done very well but it's it's it's the
most unstable career you could ever
embark on and that'll [ __ ] with your
brain in so many different ways well the
trick is to do kind of what you did
which is to get not that I this is why
I'm trying with the podcast but it has
helped for me in a way this way is to be
slightly entrepreneurial about it and
create some opportunities for yourself
so you control over your career no
waiting for someone to give you
permission yeah anything you just
actually do something that is
interesting and that resonates when
people listen to it and watch it or
whatever that they're like oh that
person's doing something that they
authentic ly enjoy and that bleeds out -
yeah you can tell when someone loves
what they're doing do you have favorite
people that you follow online yeah I
mean I love following the rock yeah he's
like inspirational and funny and like I
love that we're we kind of have a
similar build on those he was actually
his first acting was on my 70 show was
it really well fun fact yeah so I
remember meeting him and be like this
guy's got it he was so charismatic and
so good and it was his first thing he
was kind of like was that good knows
like yeah man you're like fer what I
assumed was just like a wrestler guy was
like you're fantastic
no I'm literally caught I just got back
from WrestleMania this weekend I'm a big
wrestling head and really had fingers
crossed that he would show up this
weekend he does rise what like once
every five years he kind of drops by
he'll pop in one time I did see him out
here at a like Monday Night Raw or
something he came out surprised the
audience but he was also shooting a
scene for a movie that he needed the
audience for so it's like we're being
exploited that's so fun he's also one of
those people that I - when I started
following him on Instagram and social
media that I was like he's doing it
right like he is so genuine and
authentic and like really seems like he
cares and every caption for every
Instagram is a novel and I'll read all
of it interesting hearing about it from
you who's someone who's had success in
that way I guess that's the only thing
that really matters like if you had to
lead his authenticity right well then
just it's the word that we all kind of
hate this
say but it is truly the correct word are
you listening what's the guy's name who
the guy who was gay who was lying about
it Oh Luke
are you listening Lucas authenticity in
authenticity was transparent that's what
that host was trying to tell him like
just be authentic man like people won't
care
yeah I don't know what that guy's gonna
do I'm curious but I also have nothing
continue this now is a podcast about
married at first sight I think I feel
like maybe they won't do this but part
of me really wants them to bring Kate
back the next season give her a hug okay
so obviously the rock is fantastic
how old do you feel mentally oh great
question because I constantly fluctuate
between like 13 and like 65 no I would
say I've I just turned 40 so I look at
30 as being a real sea change in my life
yeah I think a lot of people they get
other 20s and they go like you're
clearly still in your 20s but you know
what I'm done you know when you realize
like there's a you're like on like
nature gives you crack mm-hmm or like
fairy dust or something for that amount
of time you're just riding on like not
knowing how dangerous it is or how the
whole thing so to me that was a big
change but I love being 40 in terms of
what I've what I've learned
yeah so is it like a monument to like
age like did you have that kind of like
thinking about it as a number so here's
my real problem yeah I was always kind
of 40 okay so now you're finally you're
your body's caught up to your brain no I
don't mean to my like I was so smart I
was forward like I'm like lame like a 40
year old right yeah it's not my 20s I
could tell one thing was really
frustrating is I could tell women were
like someday like not right now right
now I [ __ ] this guy he's really bad news
but someday you're like gonna be like a
good dad
hey you know dude and I was really
frustrating when I was younger and now I
go it's like the weirdest fight of
friends on some I've had that where I
could tell they were like you know when
I'm falling down the tree uh-huh grab on
last thing but but I mean my wife isn't
that way she really chose me and and so
and then feeling comfortable and that
kind of thing I go like oh yeah I feel
so I don't know I feel like a very
healthy 40 but yeah I really I don't
know if I liked being 35 and dating and
yeah I kind of thought I liked it but
you know hindsight's 20/20 the how did
you and your wife meet each other we met
at a charity event which sounds really
good that sounds like you're good people
I get it good job yeah we I saw her I'm
involved with is charity and she was
involved it I saw it I does I mean it
sounds like 40 olds talking yeah of
course these two people met at a charity
yeah we were both reading the same novel
and no she I saw her at the planning
event for this it's a great charity
called Art of Elysium and so this is
like they have this big gala and this is
the kind of planning like the host
committee dinner mm-hmm I didn't even
talk to her but I knew the head of the
charity and I was like can you please
hit me next to her this gal oh my god
that's very sweet and it was great I
mean she had a boyfriend the time so
it's like okay that's how we become met
yeah
later she was single so you planted a
seed at this charity actually I just
recently had a friend tell me about
Facebook is not that long ago until like
seven years ago and I've been very I
don't really need to connect with a lot
of people from my past that's happened
for me yeah many people like come out
yeah they'll connect for you yeah so
when I when I was what happened I was
just like really single for a long
period of time you know what your
friends start to get worried kind of
yeah they said hey Facebook is kind of
like the phone book like you're just not
in it you know what I mean like
and so thank God I did it because I
didn't get her number or anything and
then looked her up on Facebook but she's
very you connected unfit I just say her
mom went with her to this thing so I
really spent a lot of time sucking up to
the mom yeah yeah you were really
planting seeds oh dang and then I
reached out her on Facebook and it was
such a Kurt I mean I still have it
because it's on Facebook like it was so
great hanging out with you and your mom
something lame and she was like thanks I
know that this woman's have my children
now but it's like you know at the time
she's like that's enough like back off
that's amazing what year is this oh why
are you doing this to me is 2030 14 2014
ah that's very sweet
yeah that's incredibly sweet so I hope
Mark Zuckerburg gave a speech at your
wedding for you guys gifted us 1% right
when you don't mean it when you get
married my parents kind of facebooking
it I was like delete I'm done I'm done
here
okay what would your high school senior
quote be if you had to make one now are
we doing on me we should be doing you
what's going on with you lately no this
is a podcast work
welcome to hosting a podcast you make it
about your guests and then sometimes you
insert your what what was the question
sorry
what would your high school quote be now
do do do boarding schools have like
superlatives and that sort of thing like
yes most likely - did you get any of
those I didn't well no follow-up
questions there sounds kind of like a
loser in hi sir my thing was very weird
in relation to getting that 70 show I
had never acted before so I did really
high school play yeah I think I read
this that some yeah okay so I had a vary
in terms of what that yearbook quote
would be it's a very like hard left turn
which is no one was talking to me I was
fine I was like kind of shy yeah and
then I went to college at USC here so I
was in LA and someone's the girl who did
the sets her parents were big producers
and they said hey would you like to come
try out
something was so bad I said um okay what
do I have to bring like I was at college
at the bus I didn't have a car
yeah USC it's like it's a far ride from
the you know a bus ride yeah and they
said just bring a picture and a resume
and I said wait what do you mean I said
we need to know when you leave your
resume who you were like we'll tell them
who you are but let just you need to
bring a picture so I brought this
picture of I mean I don't know what
supposed to be like an eight-by-ten of
me posing like a headshot it was me and
my friends at Six Flags like out in the
parking lot right we did Six Flags so I
figure I could find it myself and then
the resume was like Dunkin Donuts in
Suncoast V amazing so so then I got it I
mean they made me audition for it a lot
they really gonna give this to our
daughter's friend from right right right
I think the thing was though all the
kids are too cool product in their hair
and they looked at me we need a actual
married photo of him and his friends at
Six Flags and the fact that he's poured
iced coffees on the East Coast by the
way night shift changing oh [ __ ]
so then when I got it I was so supremely
weirded out for the next three years
because I was yeah can you imagine if
people like I couldn't get laid at USC I
remember like three there'd be like a
publicist on the project who's like
would you like to have dinner I was like
what like whoa I skipped so many steps
so I that's so nuts so I got my at first
my quote a couple years in would have
been like you know [ __ ] all of you and
then and then I've made peace with it
was just such a sharp turn to go from
being bad unpopular to popular and
there's absolutely no rulebook in which
you follow or anyone that you can relate
to to even ask like how do i emotionally
physically mentally I don't know anyone
who's gone that like hasn't auditioned
and then has a thing that's ongoing I've
seen people have an audition and then
they get one role in a thing sure then
they're back to being a normal human
but like this was like also was going
into work like I got a call
for the forget wheels together I'll tell
you one high school related fan on if
the season is I when I was doing the
spider-man movie in New York uh-huh
there was a girl who had I like I mean I
mean rejected me so hard it wasn't like
I said like you know I have friends I
can't go out that night or something
like I came up to her and she said
please like get the [ __ ] away from me
okay so I saw her in a club like at a
bar kind of Club in New York uh-huh
and I was like let's say her name was
Diane it's not sure I was like Diane and
no one has gone from having his little
confidences I had when I last saw her
and then like seven eight years later I
was like Diane how are you going on she
said oh my gosh like I can't but like I
couldn't believe it when I first turned
on TV and saw you and I said oh yeah you
know I got to tell you I always had such
a crush on you back then it was like I
was hitting her with just like I'm not
just confidence but like it was so
different than the last time she saw me
probably and she said I I had I had such
a crush on you when I was like what you
did like what a crazy game of
cat-and-mouse we played when I came to
ask you out you told me to get away from
you like I didn't now I understand that
was just you flirting with me jerk oh
wow where is she now she's dead oh god
blessed day and classic Diane why did I
choose Diane let's clearly no one I went
to school with was named well I would
respect if you're pretending that that's
a fake name and that's actually her real
name Oh that'd be great that'd be really
fun no one knows
okay we're taking one last break and we
get back we have a bunch of Twitter
questions for you people have things
they want to know we'll be right back
with more nuts you're deep
[Music]
too deep this episode of Hunter deep is
brought to you by the OkCupid dating app
OkCupid is the only dating app that
finds you someone based on who you are
and what you're into the OkCupid dating
app asks you fun and meaningful
questions that matter to you so you can
be seen by the people who are going to
be into you they have questions like
would you pay an extra five dollars for
guac are you close to your family
real light-hearted stuff like that did
you vote in the last election it's
you'll see tons of answers that lead to
great conversations and great dates with
people who feel the same way that you do
tell people about your favorite album
your last great trip your favorite
podcast and then let the love roll in on
the OkCupid dating app whether you're
looking for that person to join you on a
long walk on the beach or a very short
walk to the hotel minibar they're
waiting for you on the OkCupid dating
app be yourself and enjoy all the
awesome people who want to meet you
download the free OkCupid dating app and
find your next great date today support
for today's show comes from a Coke
Autopia after a long day well know that
we like to enjoy some me time I mean I
might be projecting onto you but I know
for myself when I'm around people all
day and hustling and bustling and busy I
want to come home and be by myself and
do my version of self-care and what a
better way to do that than with
delicious dark chocolate truffles from
Coca topia guys this okay
they're fantastic you can indulge in
delicious chocolate without the
sacrifice on calories because the dark
chocolate truffle is only 40 calories
you heard me 40 a number we hate to
associate with age but love to associate
with calories
according to chocolates it's 45 percent
fewer calories than Lindt and it has
less fat and less sugar too it's the
perfect treat after a meal during a
girl's weekend gathering or we just want
to pair it with a glass of wine it's up
to you the possibilities are endless you
can try it first off by going to cocoa
topia calm and entering promo code grace
check out to get 50% off your first
order make sure you type the code in all
caps that's going to KOCO Tokyo comm CE
o ce o-- t.o.p i a calm and enter promo
code grace gr AC e in all caps at
checkout 455 zero percent off your first
order indulge without the guilt okay
we're gonna get into these Twitter
questions before we do I'm gonna ask you
the two questions asked every single
guest that's on the podcast and the
first was who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
bring it in bring it in the [ __ ] room
I'll do it right now it's you imagine
what that would look like in there no
one ever chosen you they might have okay
the other question is to tell us your
worst pants [ __ ] story or close call
but you can only use three words or
small phrases so mine is college jogging
front lawn
I don't drink though so I think that's a
big part of it Oh
I mean God bless and God bless can I
tell the best story I've ever heard
about it yes it's not gonna be three
words that's four I would rather hear
the story this is the greatest story
anyone ever told me okay so the you know
it's not mine I repeat it is nama yeah
just full disclosure not his story okay
this guy my trying to shorten this okay
he's he was also loser in high school
again not me this is not it was dopher
so he went to college and like
accidentally got a date with the hottest
girl there like he's at orientation I
didn't know they were in the same group
and I said hey let's go to this Museum
in Connecticut or something they were in
New York okay and then the whole that
whole week he started realizing oh my
god I asked out the hottest girl at this
college and so he starts getting like
stomach issues about it good enough they
take the subway they're sorry to the to
Grand Central to take the train and he's
like I have to fart so bad and she's
talking to him and it's all he's
thinking about and then she goes
she's like oh she's our friend Robin or
something in the next car so he's like
oh thank god and he just shits himself
and he goes oh crap
and then they're pulling the Grand
Central Station and she's like he's not
saying anything about it it's kind of
drying in his past she says does it
smell like [ __ ] in here and he's like
yeah it does I know what's up with this
station so they get out and he sees like
a gap or something oh those stories in
Grand Central yeah and he has this
brilliant idea which is he goes into the
gang he says I've been like eyeing a
sweater there and she was like what and
he goes and buys the sweater and grabs
some jeans that look like his jeans it
brings up to the counter he says do me a
favor like I don't want to buy the
sweater because he's up there alone just
put the pants you know one of those big
bags you can fold it over like I don't
want the sweater I just want the pants
and so she rolls him up into the bag he
takes a bag he says let's go and they
get on the train to go out to
Connecticut and they're in one of those
compartments were one of those you know
cars that has a little bathroom thing
and it says I have to use a bathroom so
he takes it in there and he takes off
his pants and their [ __ ] just running
although he just [ __ ] hears know what
to do because if she comes in afterwards
whatever so he rolls him up and throws
him out that there's a little window you
can't commit suicide from I got a little
space we roll them through they fly out
onto the track then he takes off his
underpants which are just decimated
throws them out the window then he opens
the bag sweater no there's only a
sweater in the back oh my god what did
himself some pants already told me is it
you know how you put it around your
waist yeah he did that but put it
forward and then ran off the train when
it came to the next stop didn't know if
she saw him or not and then he switch
schools I don't wanna do any
fact-checking of any part okay it was me
that is in sane it also like truly our
animal instincts our fight-or-flight and
he he started with fight and
unfortunately chose flight consider like
kill himself oh my god that's so nuts
also like
that gap employee having to be like what
you want me to do what okay let's get
into these Twitter questions someone to
know what type of animal would you most
want to speak English Oh dog Golden
Retriever
do you have one no we had one growing up
and that was my dream in life is to hear
what's going on
I think I can still happen for you well
you know we'll see I'll hopefully be
alive for a couple years science is
pretty amazing right now so let's see
what happens also were you a lassie fan
no I hate that
okay well she knows what she did you
know what she did with all those good
deeds
yeah you think Karma's coming back
around for that [ __ ] no way so once you
know who was your childhood crush oh
like celebrity crush I guess cuz mine
was Billy Elliot when I was in high
school character the ballet dancer we
put he's an actor what's his name yeah I
couldn't tell the difference when I was
in middle school high school I just
thought he was very good at he was very
passionate and artistic and lemon he was
very like was it Bally Bally bye
well Alicia Silverstone for me was like
really and I got to I audition for
something very early on with her and I
was like if she knew how creepy the
surprise she knew she knew on some level
if she knew what's in my thoughts right
now someone said no if you could choose
a decade to set a new sitcom in what
decade would you choose I think there's
something to the 20 years thing yeah
which is the same now the Nine Muses are
ripe you know the because we're sad cuz
a happy day so I think happening is a
70s 50s for 70s right right revenues for
90s I think I think the 90s are right
but in ten years the two thousands will
be right well didn't last year was the
20th anniversary of that 70 show yes but
it was set two years it will have been
the amount of time in about two years
that was from when we started gotcha
gotcha gotcha I think in 90s 90s that
70s show well you feel that way cause
you grew up then but the kids who are
watching out for the first time Netflix
they're gonna have that level of
nostalgia about the 2000s right it's
always like whenever you kind of true
true true okay someone to note does he
have a favorite episode of catfish are
you a catfish man I'm not I'm sorry I
watched the movie though no I always
assumed when people ask these questions
that these are like sometimes personally
specific to things that you actually
enjoy mmm I haven't seen the movie but I
do watch the TV show if you were a
crayon
what would your color name be
topher orange or cerulean I am be
cerulean yeah how did that get in there
someone to know what's the weirdest /
wildest party experience he's had not
much of a partier but but you and your
wife go occasionally do you guys like
have a safe word of like we had to get
the [ __ ] out of here
oh we just saying to each other like we
got it we need to leave now
and then after having a kid it's like
game over try think weirdest party you
know when I first moved to New York
mm-hmm I had hosted Saturday live right
before that and I had an apartment and
I'm Seth Meyers and I are buddies and I
said hey come on over it's my first
night in New York let's celebrate
and he brought like half the cast of SNL
yeah and I had a karaoke machine it was
like one of those nights where you just
go I can't believe New York is a
mattress is happening yeah doing their
impressions when they were singing it
was like too much right they can't turn
it off they were my friends you know my
apartment yeah someone to know what's
been your favorite role and which one do
you think has changed your life for the
better well a couple answers mm-hmm my
favorite role of all time would be
playing Eric form and I that was like
such an amazing experience doing 70 show
like you are yeah especially cuz
I was new and we were all new yeah the
most part and like everything that was
happening in our lives was happening on
the show was when I look back it's like
um what's that uh boy's life no what's
the movie that Richard Linklater did uh
that's boyhood that's what it feels like
watching it cuz I'm like I think that
that exact thing was happening in my
life that week and they were doing a
show about it I love those kids and yeah
but I also love this movie I do with
Paul Weitz called in good company not a
lot of people saw it but it loved that
film cool and and also my wife had only
seen when a date with tad Hamilton when
we met so I oh that movie more than I
thought when I made it thought it was
like legitimately a good film and no you
didn't know she watch every show but she
had a little crush on you from that
movie sweet that's incredibly sweet is
there what do you look for now when you
audition or take on a part like are
there certain parts that you
specifically look for or is it more just
sort of getting the feeling or the the
people that you're working with it just
has to be a Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux
Klan yeah no I actually it's so funny
because it moves in different places
being an actor but like wow it's like
I'm getting all these like Nazi offers
oh my god that's kind of cool it with we
swung the pendulum really far the answer
is I really have to love the director if
they've directed once or a a bunch of
times do you direct as well no no no I
would never get out but I know the
person what's that you know your
limitations lend ya know that's a part
of being 40 yeah
the self-awareness that's in there you
go like let me help
I really want to be a great helper to
these great directors oh that's nice
that's a great way to frame that that's
very nice um a lot of people are asking
do you still talk to your cast mates
from that 70 show
oh yeah Wilmer just did he's literally
he's on the podcast right is this air
this is
uh may at the end of May he was on last
month to say it was yeah wait what did
you guys do for that episode that was
very special because Romer and I were
very very close
and one thing we do and like pop music
was on is we'd start acting out trailers
yeah we were young I mean he was like 17
and I was 19 yeah yeah and so like when
the when the song starts to like our cup
we'd be like this summer sorry you don't
I mean like how they own the biggest
movie trailer announcer in the world
come in the guy who says like in a world
way the legit like a legit guy came into
the studio and Wilmer and I learned how
to read trailers from this guy what and
work by the way when I listened back to
it I was like we are terrible right this
guy is the guy who's like you know
Aquaman raided our you know my god but
listen no Wilma do it was amazing what I
didn't even know that could be taught
how to do that well you can get a little
bit better I don't think we have the
Willmar has a pretty thick accent did
the best working with you guys with what
he could but he taught us some stuff and
also I didn't know that there was one
guy who's guys and you hear it like you
go oh yeah that's you almost don't pay
attention to him cuz he's so in our
lives all the time right yeah I guess
that makes sense that you're so used to
hearing that type of voice God or
something is talking to ya
yeah yeah very religious as close to a
god-like experiences you can get
someone's know what's a major adventure
adventure that you would want to go on
as their instead of a minor eventually
yeah has there been any thing on the
docket for minor adventures that like
you're excited to potentially maybe do
in the future
I love the constraint of it that we
could on studio right yeah but we're
starting to have ideas like wait but
what if we went to mm-hmm XYZ so maybe
in future seasons will start to
adventure at the studio yeah it'd be
cool to take like a hot-air balloon ride
and record it
Oh that'd be fun go to like Space Camp
or whatever ah see I have no ambition
for that with this podcast one you can
find
right now having a young kid it's like
not my jam yeah but maybe maybe just do
an episode where you learn you just
audition babysitters I guess this is
like a sketch or something but like we
have the babysitter arrive uh-huh and
then she's like thank you so much and I
just come out of the room and I'm like
hey you made me some food like what's up
for this guy like that's what I called
my manager
okay we've reached the end of the
podcast over thank you so much for being
here but before you go everyone you've
kind of clocked this earlier it gets a
personalized fortune cookie for being
now this looks like it's been tampered
with it has been touched for sure we
don't like to reveal or do witchcraft
here let's see what this is it was a
very very low budget it's um it's a
script I want you to read actually that
murderer met murder in trial didn't
recognize you from that 7:00 show he
thought you were a friend from middle
school was too embarrassed on your
behalf to let you know mm-hmm well if he
was he's one of these guys who made fun
of me yeah so my yearbook quote of [ __ ]
you all yeah exactly where can people
listen to your podcast we're gonna be
we'll follow you online if they don't
know I am not very good at that part I'm
gonna let you know yeah you tell me mine
our adventures with Topher Grace
official full name yeah my nerd ventures
- if you can't figure out where do we
don't watch now you can find his podcast
everywhere you listen to podcasts you
can podcast thing you know podcast.com
slash podcast and then where can people
follow you on social media if you want
that over grace yeah that's over grace
across the board I'm honestly so bad I
mean if you guys make sure I'm not that
good at this part no it's great thank
you so much for being here thank you
this is really really fun Congrats on
the podcast again I can't wait - they're
coming on right it feels like you are
potential there's a potential yes there
but you
I'll tell you what the adventure is
ahead of time yeah the adventure is
saying yes to the podcast okay thank you
guys for this today we all see you on
another purse of nacho deep goodbye too
deep too deep
go deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer and edited
by melissa demons writing by diane kang
a production assistants by Katrina
Henning post production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]